[Music]
he inserts the main drive motor and then
secures it to an aluminum partition with
the shaft protruding through the other
side
he then wraps the drive chain around the
sprockets of the shaft he loops a rubber
belt in front of the buffer brush and
connects it to the oil applicator the
applicator will slide on the belt
dispensing small amounts of conditioner
he installs whisker sensors to the front
on each side
when these whiskers brush the sides of
the lane they'll send a signal to the
computer which will then direct the
robot to move more to the center the
conditioning solution tanks have been
equipped with metering pumps and
pressure gauges he bolts the assembly to
the rear wall of the machine he pops in
the rechargeable battery and connects it
to the motor the machine is ready for
the computerized system that runs it
this system includes the control panel
he installs it in the center of the
machine just above the battery he then
runs the hose from the conditioning tank
over to the applicator and connects it
moving to the front another employee
unwinds fabric from one roller and
attaches the end to the next this is
part of the cleaning system the cloth
will scrub the bowling lane after the
robot sprays a cleaning solution onto it
a suctioning squeegee will vacuum up
dirt and leftover cleaner and deposit
them in this recovery tank
he then plugs the wiring harness into
the computer at the back of the control
panel
it's time for a dry run with no cleaner
or conditioner in the system yet the
technician powers up the robot and puts
it through its paces he confirms that
every part is in good working order
he adds cleaning solution to the tank
and it's time to prepare the lane
conditioners they mix the mineral oil
based conditioners in big blenders there
are nine different recipes with up to 16
ingredients in each one with the
conditioners approved it's time to test
the robot in special quality control
lens during 50 trips down the lanes a
technician evaluates the robots
performance he inspects it's turning
radius and the effectiveness of the
sensors
he also scrutinizes the cleaning and
conditioning job satisfied that the
conditioning robot works well on its own
he approves it for shipping this bowling
lane conditioner should be a real
game-changer and ensure that the path to
victory is a well-oiled one